[Applause]
did you guys actually get a chance to
see Donald lovers this is America oh my
thoughts reactions I loved it yeah I
feel like he's a genius period point
blank we need to be talking about gun
violence and in the United States like
we just it needs to be a conversation
that we need to have and and because
children are dying period point-blank
but like to have to speak of that and
then like have the racial undertones and
like even him being like runt like
people running after him at the end like
like I'm like a slave running off of a
plantation like the visuals of it I just
watch back and creepy and things that
are going on behind him you can get
caught up in hidden like doing this
thing and be like Donald getting it to
show you like are we tap dancing like I
mean I feel like so many people have
their time the heavy dope just rough
times it's right time it's an awakening
yeah a much-needed awakening and I think
our show you know continues like to
further those conversations that need to
be had to pill this scab off of this
post-racial you know facade and just
talk about it
the cast of Netflix's dear white people
reacting to Childish Gambino's new song
and sharing how their show is also
shining a light on national issues I
said show me some ID character is
dealing with the aftermath of his run-in
with the police officer did you have any
personal reference from that well I'm
black and a young man so you know that
experience is always you know in my
heart
and a lot of our parts so it wasn't too
hard to get there just so happens that
Reggie just lived